et voilà terminé il est pas mal mon
bateau à mon bateau c'est celui de
samantha davies qui participent au
vendée globe sous les couleurs
d'initiative coeur le vendée globe une
course mythique
la plus prestigieuse des courses à la
voile les bateaux font le tour du monde
je voudrais laventure commence aux
sables d'olonne en vendée le département
chine et 46 mille km sans escale et en
solitaire alors les bateaux ne font pas
le tour du monde au niveau de l'équateur
de toute façon il n'y a pas de passage
d'abord il met le cap au sud pour aller
chercher les alizés des vents qui
soufflent d'est en ouest et qui tournent
dans le sens des aiguilles d'une montre
ils vont leur permettre de franchir
l'équateur avec à ce niveau une
difficulté majeure le pot-au-noir une
zone où peuvent s'abattre des orages
extrêmement violents et des pluies
diluviennes pour la suite comme acheter
ranouil sur une carte
ce sera plus pratique le voilà le fameux
pot-au-noir une fois cet obstacle
franchi les bateaux contourne
l'anticyclone de sainte-hélène cette
fois une profite de vents qui tournent
dans le sens inverse des aiguilles d'une
montre et qui les pousse vers l'océan
indien
c'est là que l'on prend réellement
conscience de la taille de l'antarctique
et que l'expression tour du monde prend
tout son sens les bateaux naviguent au
niveau de ce que l'on appelle les
quarantièmes rugissants
40e parce qu'il se trouve au niveau du
40e parallèle sud
vous savez ces lignes imaginaires
parallèle les unes aux autres et qui
permettent de déterminer la latitude
d'un point à la surface du globe les
sables-d'olonne par exemple de son parti
des bateaux qui se trouve entre les 46e
et 47e parallèle au nord de l'équateur
rugissants mais ça c'est de l'autre côté
la mer et les vents sont déchaînés
normal se voit très bien sur cette car
il n'y a absolument rien pour les
arrêter
aucune terre là les navires franchise
des caps mythiques le cap de
bonne-espérance le cap levine au sud de
l'australie et le cap horn à la pointe
de l'amérique du sud
quand on vit dans l'hémisphère nord on a
un peu de mal à s'imaginer la distance
parcourue
voilà ce que donnerait un tel itinéraire
au niveau du 40e parallèle nord il passe
par la turquie l'azerbaïdjan le
turkménistan traverse toute la chine
l'océan pacifique nord tous les états
unis et l'océan atlantique nord
bon revenons au vendée globe
puis les bateaux remonte l'océan
atlantique franchissent le pot-au-noir
avec les mêmes difficultés qu'à l'aller
vont chercher les alizés pour contourner
l'anticyclone des açores et il rentre à
la maison
rien de raconter l'itinéraire je suis
complètement épuisé bon il était pas mal
mon bateau mais si on allait jeter un
oeil sur le vrai
[Musique]
le voilà le bateau initiative coeur en
grandeur nature 18 mètres de long 5
mètre 70 de large
le marché lui aussi 18 mètres de hauteur
la surface de voile peut atteindre 600
m² un joli bébé
y'a quelqu'un à salut bonjour sam on
peut visiter
bonjour avec plaisir oui il y est ça
j'arrive
sur la tête alors on est où ici on est à
l'intérieur du bateau initiative coeur
qui grandes dalles extrêmes et l'espace
où je vis et du petit tu vis uniquement
dans cet espace pendant toute la course
oui oui j'ai tout ce qu'il faut ici
devant j'ai la soute à voiles pour
ranger les voiles derrière je stocke un
petit peu la nourriture mais en gros
c'est les espaces vides avec des clauses
un étanche pour la sécurité du bateau et
là j'ai tout ce qu'il faut ici ça c'est
le poste de navigation exactement la
navigation téléphone satellite à table à
cartes où j'ai l'ordinateur pour la
navigation les dix pièces la stratégie
aussi communications emails gens voient
les vidéos depuis le téléphone satellite
qui est ici aussi je peux commander le
de télécommande de pilote je peut barrer
le bateau depuis ici et j'ai les infos
sur la force du vent etc
et puis juste derrière j'ai un petit lit
c'est un petit couche est donc avec un
matelas en bis parce que le bateau bouge
beaucoup il faut que je suis bien amorti
est là je peux vraiment injuste et si
que ça agite ça penche beaucoup je tombe
pas et je peux je peux voir en fait la
navigation les chiffres à la vitesse du
bateau depuis monnaie en étant bien calé
alors dans un bateau il faut se nourrir
aussi oui on mangeait à la cuisine c'est
un tout petit meuble là ici avec juste
ici avec un réchaud à gaz signés de
camping qui bouge aussi avec les
mouvements du bateau région et puis
alors dernière question le sur un bateau
ont fait sa toilette aussi les sels de
bain c'est ici dans sa salle de bain en
fait j'en ai deux normalement il ya une
c'est des toilettes et l'autre c'est la
douche la même couleur même coup là mais
j'avais une noté dessus ah oui on s'est
trompé il faut mais pas se tromper
donc on est un peu à l'étroit ici on
retourne faire un tour à l'extérieur
aller
là on est dans ton jardin ou sur la
terrasse plus tôt ça manque un peu de
verdure mais il ya une très belle vue
sur la mer alors à quelle vitesse il va
ce bateau et il va jusqu'à 35 noeuds ça
c'est un poids de 50 km à la sas est
énorme pour un bateau bah oui c'est mes
graphiques mais alors s'il peut
atteindre une telle vitesse c'est grâce
à sa surface de voile à sa silhouette
mais aussi à ses appendices qui sortent
de chaque côté qui sont énormes et qu'on
appelle des foils oui jamais c'est faux
elles elles sont capables de porter le
poids du bateau alors ses foils sont
capables de porter le poids du bateau
bougez pas je vous explique samantha qui
m'attend ici jeu dans l'atelier et je
reviens tout de suite
[Musique]
parfois il ne suffit pas de regarder la
réalité en face il faut aussi l'observer
de profits vu sous cet angle un fol
ressemble à une aile d'avion en coupe
grâce à ce profil quand le bateau avance
l'eau est dévié vers le bas comme le
fait l'ale d'un avion avec l'air ensuite
c'est le principe d'action réaction
quand un corps exerce une force sur un
autre corps il subit en réaction une
force d'intensité égale dirigé dans le
sens opposé très concrètement le foil
des villes haut vers le bas et par
réaction
une force d'intensité égale s'exerce
vers le haut c'est ce qu'on appelle la
portance le bateau est moins immergé il
y a moins de résistance moins de traînée
il va donc plus vite qu'on essaye allez
c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on samantha on va peut-être faire demi
tour parce que j'ai des choses à faire
pendant les deux mois qui viennent
allez à très bientôt si je rentre
[Musique]
j'avais oublié de vous dire si je suis
monté sur le bateau de samantha davies
c'est non seulement parce que c'est une
excellente navigatrice mais aussi parce
que je suis ambassadeur de l'opération
initiatives coeur l'objectif consiste à
réunir des fonds pour sauver des enfants
qui sont atteints de graves maladies
cardiaques et qui nécessite une
intervention chirurgicale qui ne peut
pas avoir lieu dans leur pays pour les
soutenir
il vous suffit pendant toute la durée de
la course d'aller sur la page facebook
d'initiative coeur ou sur le compte
instagram et liens apparaissant
description de vous abonner à chaque
abonnement
les sponsors reverse un euro à
l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque qui se charge d'accueillir les
enfants en france est de financer
l'intervention chirurgicale
ces enfants ont besoin d'un nouveau
souffle pour avancer comme le bateau de
samantha besoin de vendre à très bientôt
je te refais une entière tireur pourquoi
des orages extrêmement violente et des
puits des deals en main au kop reste ici
toi de déterminer l'aptitude d'un point
la surface du très concrètement